and on the mound for the houston astros
kickoff this lone star series is
christian javier
2-0 with a 2-9-2 versus texas last
season so
looking forward to face the rangers
again six starts this season a 2.90 era
here comes willie calhoun stepping in
against the right-hander you can see
there from the light roof open beautiful
evening in houston as willie swings at
the first pitch and it's a fast ball and
it is hammered to right field gone
one pitch in willie calhoun
chases a pitch above the zone
and just like that the rangers take a
one-nothing lead
not a customary pitch that you swing at
first pitch of the game it looked up and
out of the strike zone but when you're
ready to hit you're ready to hit why not
start the game with the bang one nothing
rangers
swing and a miss high fast ball and
gallow goes down swinging javier bounces
back after the lead-off home run to get
the net three
two strikeouts in the mix one-nothing
rangers
on seven starts this year mike fulton
carries a 4-5 era into this game doesn't
walk many opponents are hitting a little
better off him than average but mainly
the lefties not the righties this ball
is set up the middle for a base hit
jose altuve with a nine game hitting
streak continues to have a hit in every
game since turning 31. the astros have
two on with one out for jordan alvarez
and the pitch
swing and a miss he struck him out
nasty slider to get him
so two strikeouts now for fulton
correa hitting 255 five homers 16 rbis
and the 1-2 fastball on the corner
called strike three and mike foltenevich
out here painting against the astros in
the first inning
and the bases are loaded with nobody out
back-to-back walks to dahl and connor
falefa as charlie culberson's coming up
beating 295 three homers and 11 runs
batted in
swing and a miss got him with a good
fastball christian javier with
strikeout number three and a big first
down here in the second inning
jose trevino steps in now with one out
bases loaded an opportunity and he
swings at a slider and lists a fly ball
into center field
straw is there garcia is going to tag
he'll score easily without a throw
and the rangers now lead two to nothing
two outs now for calhoun
and that is lined right out altuve makes
the catch had to leave his feet slightly
and the enemy is over rangers load the
bases with nobody out only get one run
out of it the astros have loaded them up
jose altuve who ripped a single up the
middle his first time first pitch
and altuve grounds it left side and that
gets past culverson and goes down the
left field line scoring his tucker diaz
scores around third castron coming home
the throw to the plate by connor falefa
not nearly in time castro slides in
altuve at second and the astros lead in
three to two that ball absolutely eight
up charlie culverson
94 mile an hour fastball is lifted deep
to left field willie calhoun up against
the wall makes the catch altuve was on
the move to throw in a second he's out
double play great play by willie calhoun
first to catch the baseball
and then double up jose altuve that was
poor base running right there by jose
altuve to run the astros out of that
inning so the rangers have the tying run
90 feet away with only one out here in
the top of the third and joey gallo
coming up the 1-0 offering and here it
comes a swing and a ground ball inside
first fielded by diaz he wanted to throw
home but he's not going to make that
throw instead he takes it to the bag
solac races across the plate and we're
tied at three
that'll push miles straw up to second
base as a third walk allowed by the
former astro first rounder here's
michael brantley
ground ball hit to the left side diving
play by isaiah counterfeit he goes to
third
and
straw is ruled safe
that's really close right there and i
feel i don't know from that angle it
seems like culverson got him one way or
another it does feel like this should go
the ranger's way here
all right good challenge by the rangers
the 2-2
a little jam shot fly ball into right
field but it stays in the air for joey
who moves in a bit to his left to haul
it in and bregman is the final out in
the inning
jordan alvarez will lead things off
against mike foltenevich
that ball's rocketed in the left center
field that ball will be off the wall one
hop pinball's around out there and that
cove in left center field as jordon
alvarez on a 10 pitch at bat doubles to
left center
let's go ahead and get to a chevy game
break with leslie mccaskill
to go to get through the season as this
fastball is lifted to center but garcia
is there and after a leadoff double mike
fulton image once again
pitches around trouble
bradley 0 for three
reaching the fielder's choices last time
the pitch and that's line down the right
field line headed toward gallow he can't
get there and it hops over the wall
that'll be a ground rule double as
casserole have to stop at third if that
stayed in play castro would have had a
shot at scoring rangers trainer is out
to check on gallo they're going out
toward yeah looks like it chris woodward
turned his ankle he's telling him he's
okay differently
as this one is popped up
and john king's going to get out of this
one garcia is under it he makes the
catch and the inning is over
so christian javier who has been
outstanding since a little bit of a
struggle in the first couple of innings
we'll start things off here in the
seventh inning facing the numbers six
seven and eight hitters with 93 right
now probably has this hitter in the next
hitter and that's it
swing and a miss got him to chase the
slider
that was a
well-placed pitch by javier picking up
his fifth strikeout
so now he'll face the number nine hitter
jose trevino trying to get through the
seventh
2-2 count to trevino
[Applause]
call third strike outside edge
javier strikes out the last two of the
night
seven innings the last four innings only
allowing one hit
el reptile bringing it for that six
strikeout
tie ball game
two walks this inning for stanic if he
can get that split down in the zone or
maybe elevate a little bit more and get
that fastball past garcia to finish off
this inning swing and a miss he got him
rye stanek gets through the eighth
inning with that split
and the flowing locks of stanic finish
off the eighth castro's three rangers
three ryan presley into the ball game
pitch on the way
at the knees for strike three dahl is
frozen and that is out number one here's
charlie culverson who's over three
three two again
ground ball left side waiting on it
correa he gathers it in throws to first
ending over one two three inning for
ryan presley but we go to the 10th so
now runners at the corners with nobody
out chris davis announced as the pinch
hitter for eli white 3-1
ground ball towards third glove by
bregman
to second for one double play
how about it
astros turn a double play bregman to
altuve to diaz
try and finish off the inning with nick
solak at the plate he's one for four
with an infield hit and a run scored
swinging a miss
abreu fired up as he jumps off the mound
after that strikeout
he shuts down the rangers in the top of
the tent
so straw at the plate
rangers have walked the bases loaded
after
mccormick got the third on the ground
ball he's the winning run infield in and
straw is going to be a tough guy here is
a fly ball hit to the right man and joey
gallo we'll see what mccormick's going
to do he's coming home here comes the
throw from gallow and mccormick is out
what a throw by joey gallo on the money
mccormick is out we go to the 11th
inning and yep they're going to put
bregman on so it's going to be up to
chaz mccormick now he bats with two outs
and the base is loaded a chance to be a
hero
bounces away here comes strong going to
score the game-winner
milo straw flying down the line on a
pitch of the dirt and the astros walk it
off with straw speed to score the run
and win it 4-3